yeah we had a question from Mrs garlic
around
um food waste and I think we're going to
ask if that can go to health scrutiny
um in the next Municipal year and
because she was asking us about
um obviously explain what she was asking
she was asking why if you're a single
person
do you have to go to the supermarket and
buy a pack of X when really should be
able to buy one chart or you know two
apples or whatever it is that you want
and she was talking about the the the
amount of food waste that we have so I
think that that's something we're going
to ask Health security to have a look at
for us
or did you have an answer I do oh
brilliant.com
I do have an answer so it was and um the
two parts of her question were how many
households in the borough were single
person households to which the answer is
29.5 of our 96 000 96 269 households
29.5
are single person households and the
second part of the question was about
household waste waste
um and I think
I think perhaps this I mean I think it's
a very interesting question and I think
it probably ties into the developing
food strategy for Trafford because there
are many many facets to this question I
think probably the ability to buy
smaller portions of food is probably
available in most of the borough and
also for but many people for economic
reasons will choose to buy a larger
portion size because it will be cheaper
and then they'll store it um in their
fridge or in their freezer or perhaps
batch cook obviously for a lot of people
and the affordability of cooking has
been a real issue as has the um for some
people obviously even the storage of it
but also the ability and the the um uh
the you know different people enjoy
cooking it's a very very different
amount so some people may well just not
enjoy cooking even if they can't afford
it I think there is a question a wider
question about
um if people are living predominantly on
ready meals and I'm not suggesting that
that is the case
um then there are obviously some health
concerns about a diet that's very high
in highly processed food
um so there is a particular issue about
a diet that's particular that will be
high in highly processed foods because
it's likely to be too high in sugar salt
and fat to be a really healthy diet so I
think I think the the in terms of how
much of the other reason the other thing
she was talking about was whether having
larger portions adds to a lot of food
waste and again the answer to that is it
really does depend in a lower income
family you're very much likely less
likely to waste any food there is
confusion in up in the public between
best before you dates and use by dates
and again I think this is something that
a food strategy for Trafford and tying
into the greater Manchester the
emergency greater emerging greater
Manchester food strategy is something
that all of these aspects will be picked
up so I hope that answers at least
starts to answer the question
thank you Elena
and our feedback to Mrs garlic because
she lives in my ward thank you
and if we can move on
um item five trusted local
transformation plan for children and
young people people's mental health is
that right thank you Sally
so will it be shown on the screen enough
[Music]
we've got the presentation does do
people want it on the overhead yeah do
you want it on the overhead yes yes we
can burn it on the overhead
okay
I went to Mrs Garlic's for dinner once
and I got it
thank you
should be
it's just always really stressful
um
[Music]
okay so I'll just introduce myself first
and foremost I'm Sally Atkinson um
specialist commissioner for children's
clinical commissioning so my arena is
send Community Health Services and
children's mental health and Crisis Care
so I wanted to come speak to you today
about the local transformation plan so
it's a document that's been published
um every year since 2015 and every area
every what was ccg's
um used to have to publish something
every year and to show the
um how local services will invest in
resources to improve children young
people's mental health across the whole
children's system
So the plan should be transparent
organic living document locally
developed by Partnerships that include
the NHS local Authority Children's
Services the vcse in third sector
education Justice agencies and children
young people and their families and
carers
the ltp sets out delivery against
National key lines of inquiry and
strategic priorities in line with the
NHS long-term plan so we like our
acronyms don't we in health so that's
another ltp but this is a different ltp
that we're talking about today
so in October 2020 we received the key
lines of inquiry for to audit ourselves
against for this year
and that audit then goes back to that GM
system
um including rug ratings on each
priority area which provides assurance
and references of what is in place are
in development locally for delivery on a
high level of priorities
so traffic's local transformation plan
and the refresh outlines our ambition to
support children young people and
families mental health and well-being
there's five key priorities areas that
and the ltp covers
and that's improving access to effective
support
caring for the most vulnerable
accountability and transparency shaping
the workforce and promoting resilience
prevention and Early Access
so as it was the ccg's responsibilities
previously locally to publish an ltp it
this responsibility now moving forward
will be that of the gmicb
so an ltp will be a regional document
moving forward
so the ask of the board today from
myself is how do we want to proceed
locally with our ltp for Trafford
so option one would be for us to not
publish anything locally and for us to
feed into that GM ICB ltp which we will
do anyway because it needs to be
representative of all 10 localities
but I wanted to just run through break
briefly um an idea
um which will bring us in line with our
mft locality
authorities so Manchester and Salford
which is seems to be a way forward that
we're working towards at the moment
because a lot of our Mental Health
commission services are commissioned on
an mft footprint
so
The Proposal is to adopt a Salford model
on trafford's directory local off local
offer
it will be to develop an annual summary
and I'm not sure if you've seen it on
the emails but it's quite a lengthy
document there's a I think it's about 60
Pages or something so
um what it would mean is an addendum
would be created to each ltp each year
to provide a summary in terms of update
of what health has been developed since
the last published ltp
on there it will include accompanying
documents so we can
um really flesh that out in terms of you
know including our strategic priorities
for children young people's mental
health and that's not just for our
commission services but as a population
mental health
um overview as well
so the platform would include our
strategic priorities plans for for our
Mental Health Services and moving
towards the mft footprint delivery and
it'll support the development of a
Thrive Hub and culture in Trafford in
line with our neighboring areas
so I've just added some slides on here
from what salford's offer currently
looks like which is on their directory
so I've done this in a bit of a gradual
approach because we have a directory but
we don't have anything to this level in
terms of content around our mental
health offer
so the proposal is for us to develop
something like this on our traffic
directory where the ltps historically
will sit on there with those addendums
and then also that other information
around public health and our
um strategic priorities and how how we
responded to covid basically and a
holistic overview of how we deliver
against Children's Mental Health in
Trafford
and so that's what it would look like in
the first instance
but once we've established this we would
want to move more towards a Manchester M
Drive
um which is more of a public facing
website this has been developed
um by a company who came in and did this
on behalf of Manchester and this is
something that Salford are currently
progressing at the moment
Manchester will also include some
information on that on a much smaller
scale around Trafford and Salford so it
gives that more holistic overview of
Manchester self and Trafford as a
footprint
So eventually this is what we would like
to get to so it's very straightforward
and easy for our children young people
to access the information that they need
so it's at the right place and at the
right time
and but in order to do this we need to
take that first step of developing what
we've got currently on our local
directory so we can then feed into a
more of a well what would probably be a
tea Thrive and as opposed to an M Drive
in the future
so some key highlights from the ltp it
showcases some great progress and
transformation programs that are
underway in Trafford the fact that it's
60 Pages speaks in itself I mean about
all the great work that we do and all
the great services that we've got in
Trafford it also highlights and
identifies areas requiring Focus such as
children young people's Mental Health
Services as a wider system such as
increasing referrals waiting times and
joined a more joined up system approach
so localities are moving towards
different ways of working working on the
mft footprint as I've mentioned and
these currently work underway to improve
how our mental health offering Trafford
and in 2022 we um
brought in a company called
um Assurance quality Alliance also known
as Aqua to
um carry out a mental health review
the outcome of the review was
um there was five key themes that came
out of that review and what we've done
is establish a Steering group with
multi-agency representation across the
children's system in Trafford and to
take forward these five main themes that
was entered identified so theme one is
improving mental health into adulthood
through prevention and early
identification and a big part of that is
our not to 19's agenda with our Public
Health Team
theme two supporting families to
self-care and access Services approach
appropriately through the provision of
high quality information and advice so
this links in more to our engagement
strategies co-production and to make
sure that we really have that the voice
of the child and the voice of our
families involved in the work that we do
theme two to support our children and
people and families to access the
appropriate Care at the appropriate time
so one of the key recommendations from
the mental health review was for us to
adopt a single point of access for all
our referrals to come through one Avenue
so that means families will receive
support earlier and they will also be
signposts to the right support for them
at that time and they'll also receive
um signposts in and any support that
they can access while they wait to
support and receive that intervention
so theme for enabling the Health and
Social care system to support the mental
well-being of our children families and
Workforce so this is about training and
development for our Frontline services
and our social workers to make sure that
they're fully equipped to support our
children young people and day to day in
their work
and theme five to home and listen to our
children young people's Workforce mental
health wellbeing mental wellbeing and to
ensure we respond and this is around
that engagement in communication again
because this was a key theme that came
up through and throughout all the
workshops that we held
so to take this work forward task and
finish groups have been set up to take
each of these themes forward and that
feeds into that Steering group
and that's the end of my presentation
and does anybody have any questions
uh having read through the um the report
there are a few things that um I wonder
if we could um note uh I mean clearly
there's a lot higher referrals that are
coming through yeah not all of them
associated with covert but I'm sure yeah
quite a lot will be in and the loss of
education and and so on despite uh best
efforts that everybody's made so I think
that that is quite
um important I think the review
um needs to if it's possible and you
might say at the moment that we haven't
got census data for the latest census
data but the data we've got is going
back to 2011. yeah and and really you
know it could be a whole different
um ball game now yeah I think
particularly for uh black and ethnic
minority yeah um because you know things
do change a lot in in 10 11 days
um I'd sort of refer you to the work
that's going on in Urgent Care yeah at
the moment
um and uh healthwatch has done a report
uh on uh mental health within that and I
think that that needs to come into this
and to be uh updated people have got
very specific problems about access and
there's uh sort of uh grumbles about
um services having higher access
requirements and so on so I think that's
going to the Trafford locality board
next week and you should then
um be available for you to have a look
at and I think the big thing here is
about Workforce and finance
if we don't have the workforce and we
don't have the money none of the rest of
this is going to work as we hope yeah
that it will do but I do think it really
is a an area of high priority for all of
us children's and so they'd be uh they'd
be my comments I can't agree anymore
with you around everything you've just
said and so the report that you've
mentioned that healthwatch has done I
would I would say that that's a prime
example of something that would need to
be included on our directory so it's got
that different point of view and look at
the work that we're doing not just by
the local Authority in the ICB and
public health but also as yourselves as
well and in terms of the urgent care and
we're dealing him with Eleanor and the
work that they're doing I work a lot on
the crisis care side of it and there is
a big piece of work going on at the
moment to try and make sure that the
offer that we have a question isn't a
postcode Lottery there's a standardized
offer so that if a child presents in
hospital then it doesn't matter where
they live you know or where the GP is
they can go and access the same service
at any hospital so and yeah I completely
agree with everything that you said
um in terms of the census so this this
document was actually written last year
and it's just that so the one we put so
we publish it at the end of every year
so that information we we didn't have
access to it at the time when this was
written so when we do do the summary
report it will be based on that Census
Data as well so thank you
thank you Heather and um thank you Sally
if there's no further questions
um it's a really interesting report it's
really a really important piece of work
for us in Trafford because if we want to
you know stop people falling into crisis
we need to we need to get there early on
don't we so thank you for all your hard
work and I think it'd be really
interesting when we publish the next
report to look at the two differences
over that year um 10 years of the census
so thank you very much for coming today
thank you
yes thank you thank you so much it's
really interesting thank you
foreign
move on to
item six greater Manchester integrated
care partnership partnership strategy oh
God happens to me sometimes my mouth
gets all stuck and I can't speak and so
I think Tom you were going to feedback
on this for us weren't you but I think
it's really important to note that you
know the points that we raised as
Trafford are now included in this report
so you know we do have that voice into
the integrated care partnership so I
think it's you know great work that's
been done by staff so over to you Son
thank you thanks Chad um and just to
introduce myself for those who might not
know me so uh Tom Maloney program
director across Health and Care and a
joint appointment between the local
Authority and nhsgm Trafford and so
colleagues who were at the meeting at
this board in January will remember that
we tabled um a previous version of the
strategy and we had a really healthy
debate amongst Partners around the
things that needed strengthening the
things that wasn't there that we thought
um that should be there
um and although there are still a few
missing bits in this some of that is
down to sequencing and it working its
way through the GM Machinery I think and
I'll come on to speak a little bit more
about
um the giant forward plan um where I
think actually some of the suggestions
from last time around are on real
tangible measures that's where we'll
start to see the development of those
and the inclusion of those so I'll come
back on that in a minute
um so as colleagues recall Warren came
as chief officer for strategy at GM
um to our last uh meeting and we had a
really healthy debate in in the locality
board it was and we came here with the
same report and very much had a very
similar set of feedback all that has
been included in the revised version
which has been sent round to you and
included in the papers today
that document
um that you all have in front of you
um went to the GM giant plankton
delivery committee on the 14th of March
this week issued the week previous and
just to pick up on some of the points
that weren't specifically addressed that
we had fed back through the locality
board on the health and wellbeing boards
feedback was that we wanted to be more
explicit around the resource and the
resourcing of the priorities and and the
perceived um
the word I'm looking for I think it was
Radical but it was that was used
um radical strategy that we need to
implement and addressing the sort of
Health need and disparity and that sort
of including that sort of proportionate
universalism
being clearer about each of the missions
and I think this is something that will
get picked up in the in the giant um
forward plan so that's where the
delivery of this strategy will become a
real thing and I think that is a really
important point to know because that's
where the health and wellbeing board can
have a real say on addressing um the
tangible um work programs that are
contained within those overarching games
of the strategy
you'll see that I think there's been
some strengthened content on Net Zero on
social value I think that's in
particular importance because of the
work we're leading here in terms of the
social value charts are in Trafford and
the anchor institution work happening at
a GM level as well and also around the
inclusion of and I think a strong advice
for the importance of pcn's primary care
and our neighborhood model again all
links through to our big ticket
priorities here in Trafford
Heather you'll be glad to know there is
a public uh facing version going to be
made and that's going to be readily
available very soon so you won't have to
sift through 45 pages of strategy but
there'll be something that's digestible
for
um for job blogs so I think that's
really important and a very it was a
good point to make so that's uh that's
underway
um and as I think I've already alluded
to those progress measures which are
still missing I think that comes as part
of that joint forward plan delivery and
just so people are aware the giant
forward plan is a five-year document
with an accompanying 12-month
operational plan and the deadline for
that five-year giant forward plan
um is the end of June and so we have an
opportunity at Future meetings I think
the next meeting of this board is May
the 18th we've got a future we have the
ability to have a follow-up conversation
on that giant forward plan in whatever
draft phase is at that point in time
um it is intended that this strategy now
is going to be finalized on the 24th of
March next week
um and then the immediate attention will
turn to that giant um forward plan as
I've as I've described and I think
that's where um as opposed to having
lots of more comments now on on the
content of the the draft strategy that
you see in front of you I think our
energy and expertise will be best spent
on really sort of refining and
developing that giant forward plan so
that it does
um at Trafford communities and people
um the service that it requires so I
think it has to sing to the inequalities
that were we Face our health and
well-being board strategy our locality
plan and so I think that's the role of
the health and well-being board in terms
of challenging if that's proportionate
and addressing the needs of our
population here in Trafford as would
every other area greats Manchester so
I'll pause at that point and just
welcome any reflections thank you
does anybody yeah
thanks Jen thanks Tom for the paper I
think it has
moved on quite a bit I mean it's still a
very lengthy document isn't it you know
as you said to looking forward to seeing
the public facing one I think I just
wanted
to mention the financial context really
and we talked about this last time that
I think it's really important everybody
knows that yep all sectors are facing a
huge Challenge and the iacb nhsgm are
facing a significant financial challenge
moving into the new Financial year I
mean it is you know significant so so
not to be all doom and gloom it's just
we need to be brave as a wide assistant
don't we to to do things differently and
challenge ourselves because if we don't
then we'll just get the same and things
will not improve like we see in this
strategy because it's all the right
things in there it's just how we get
that into
and robust delivery plans with that
challenge we've got around Workforce and
finances I just I just think it's
something that we really need to
challenge ourselves to to be able to do
that it was otherwise it'll just be the
same moving forward thanks Jeff
um I think it's a fantastic document to
really welcome it and it fits very
neatly into our own health and
well-being board strategy so I think one
of the huge benefits of this is having
that Synergy between the the regional or
sub-regional and our local work so that
is I really really welcome that
um my only comment would be is that I
think and I think this is my last health
and well-being but I try not to be
totally gloomy all the way through but
um I am concerned that you know we we've
we've been very well versed and we've
discussed frequently haven't we at this
world in other places the specific
challenges we're facing in Trafford and
in greater Manchester related to
inequalities but also related to just
the pressures that are on the system
through thankfully having you know it's
fantastic to have a population who is
living longer but that does put more
pressure onto the system but also our
rates of inactivity as picked up in this
report and and we've rehearsed many
times here smoking rates and
is um
uh obesity and weight management are all
contributing to us having poorer health
and I don't want to add on yes another
challenge into the system but I do think
this report is a bit weak on the work
that we're going to need not only about
mitigating reducing the risk from
climate change but actually adapting to
the climate change that is actually
built into our system at the moment so I
think we need to be thinking that
actually the the with if we're likely to
be getting up to the two to three point
degrees of warming which is going to
have big impacts from 2050 but actually
it means that things like the heat waves
that we had last summer the potential
for extreme weather events and flooding
those we I think we need to start
recognizing that those are actually
built into our current practice we are
not going back down from them so we are
going to need to think about how we
design our systems to manage heat waves
and extreme weather and I think that
context needs to be built into our
greater Manchester strategy because when
we we've not really had to think about
how we plan around weather apart from us
one-off extreme events that we rally
around and deal with actually we need to
be planning those weather events into
our thinking
um
leads to conversations about how we heat
our homes how we cool our homes all
sorts of things but if we don't reflect
that into our health plans we are really
in danger of being on the back foot
every time something happens
thank you yeah I think Tom alluded to
the um the joint forward plan in June
and I just think the criticality of
getting the right detailed actions and
also influencing any potential
um funding shift within that is going to
be critical
um and I think the the alignment to the
objectives in in Trafford is there in
the strategy but we need to make sure
it's in that detailed action plan as
well
thank you and and thanks for your
contributions I think that you know the
points that you make Ellen I think that
you know in GM I think there was a
realization that climate change is is
dry is a driving factor and I think that
you know it might not be completely
explicit in the work that we're doing
here but actually it's always at the
back of everybody's mind that we have to
get it right for the future because if
we don't there's going to be you know
serious consequences gone Joe
yeah it was um thank you um it was just
a suggestion really around
um on the behaviors because it's it's
almost what you're saying it's that
ingrained
Behavior around thinking sustainably and
that carbon reduction rather than a sort
of another action so maybe just sort of
a feedback of how do you how do you run
that thread through without it sort of
becoming
um all incorporating I'm at the
partnership board on next Friday so I
think that we'll I'll just highlight
that perhaps we need to add more a bit
more in around
um around that issue so thanks thanks
everybody for your contributions and so
if we can move on then to item seven and
Trafford health and wellbeing board
governance and work program I think it
was going to be Manish but
um is it going to be you Tom I think it
was going to be Manish but he's had to
give his apologies doesn't it so over to
you I think that might have been another
item chair possibly um but yeah not to
worry um so I think me and Ellen are
going to do a double act on on this one
so I'm going to do the first half of the
paper and then pass over to Eleanor
um
so again this is a paper that builds on
the previous conversation we had in
January around the health and wellbeing
boards work plan and Link back to the
Deep Dives but it also um covers off
um a set of suggestions around our
future governance arrangements and tries
to strengthen I think what has been a
really um interesting and and
um positive Journey over the last 12
months um through that deep dive process
and now I think with the parallel work
around the locality board and it
formalizing its governance which I'll
touch upon in a minute and I think this
is a fantastic opportunity to strengthen
the health and well-being board moving
forward and so we'll cover off both the
governance Arrangements ask for some
support to delve into a bit more work
outside of this meeting and also to look
at the um detailed work plan I'm going
to come back to the recommendations
because I'm conscious that there's quite
a few at the front of the report so
we'll cover off those as we go through
quickly and and circle back to them at
the very end
so hopefully people will be aware that
we've gone through a really rigorous
process with an independent review of
the health and wellbeing board and that
culminated in um I suppose the full
support of the strategy that we have and
that that is absolutely tied into the
greater Manchester integrated care
partnership and it is reflective of what
we need to do here in Trafford to make
better lives for people and following
that independent route we did our deep
Dives last year and they um at the other
end they came out with 14 big
recommendations and we tabled them here
last time around and there was unanimous
support for driving those 14
recommendations forward what we've done
since then is we've looked at developing
smart targets for each of those 14
recommendations and Ellen is going to
cover the detail on that
in that period of Time new guidance was
received at the very back end of last
year around the new roles of health and
wellbeing boards in the context of
emerging integrated Care Systems and and
their establishment
um so it feels like a really as I said
opportune moment to think about the
connections and system connectivity of
the health and wellbeing board with the
new governance that we have
I think it's important to note that the
health and wellbeing world still retains
that far more statutory committee status
within the local Authority working with
Partners to improve the lives of people
really focusing on and establishing a
sense of place and what we do here in
Trafford but playing into a wider
sub-regional context as well being a
forum for joint working and making sure
that we are addressing and improving the
well-being of our local population but
also being a contributor to setting the
Strategic direction of our Trafford
system
did you the duties and the guidance
um that was updated also as I said and
referred to took into account the
establishment of ics's and at one point
there was that area of gray in terms of
what will be done by a locality boards
and what will be done by health and
wellbeing boards and I think we've come
and this hopefully this paper
articulates how we will work in Synergy
with each other and complement each
other's work and act in a reciprocal
peering challenge process
I think in point 2.4 and I think this is
a this is I do want to just raise these
actual all of these points if I can
because I think it's really important
for um how this shapes out the work of
this board moving forward so we've
listed what we feel are then it's not
exhausted there are other things that we
can bring into this space but these are
the areas of responsibility that fall
within the board so it talks about the
better care fund plans and the signing
off of those it talks about the
development and publication of our giant
um strategy um at a local level it talks
about our jsna and the publication of
the dph's annual Public Health Report
um and and a list of others but more
importantly
um because those are the things we know
when we were already supportive of and
bringing through this forum but actually
we have a role now to consider the ICP
strategy I'm really glad to say we've
been doing that over the last couple of
months we have a role to consider that
joint forward plan and influence that on
a Trafford level
um and consider the annual reports that
the ICB must um produce
it also interestingly
um the health and wellbeing board will
be a forum that receives and can and
considers the ICB and all their partner
and Trust uh The Joint capital resource
use plan as well so I think that's
something new for this forum that we
haven't had here before so that will be
learning and it'll be interesting to see
how we feed that into our work plan and
also uh the performance assurance and
assessment of the ICP at its broadest
level as well so some new
responsibilities that we we need to hold
here within the health and wellbeing
board all of that I think helps us form
a very detailed work plan for the next
12 months on a rolling basis uh coupled
with the detail that element will go
into in a minute in terms of the
tangible action plans on our five deep
dive areas
um with all of that said I think it's
really important that we revisit our
terms of reference so asking for support
to do that outside of this meeting and
bring back a revised terms of reference
to this meeting when we reconvene in May
and I'll Circle back to those
recommendations at the end
I've referred to the connectivity of the
health and well-being board with the
locality board which I'm really pleased
to say as of yesterday was formally
accepted by gmicb so the locality board
will now have its far more governance
effective as of the 1st of April and
that's really really positive
um that does mean that there has to be a
really close relationship between the
health and well-being model and the
locality board to make sure that we are
working
um to the same strategies and adding
value to each other's work and as I said
before it's that reciprocal peer
challenge process where we can help and
support each other in delivering the
work and the duties and responsibilities
that each board is responsible for
ultimately with the goal that we address
Health inequality to improve people's
lives in Trafford
there is within the um guidance coming
from Central that localities may wish to
revise their local health and wellbeing
boss strategies given the information
and and Eleanor's articulation of the
importance of that strategy and it's its
relevance at this moment in time we
don't think that's necessary it might be
something we want to consider at a point
in time in the future when we start to
think about locality plans and the
updates of those but at this moment in
time I think we're comfortable with that
strategy remains um absolutely the right
uh the right document and the right
guidance
um there is a very simple organogram on
diagram one within within and that just
shows some of and I I must stress this
some of the governance that this board
connects to and I think it's important
to know there are other really key
forums particularly that provide a
collaborative board and the Trafford
clinical and practitioners Center
um all of which will have key roles to
play so we need to think about the
informal and the formal relationships
this board has with other parts of the
Trafford system
um we would really like the opportunity
I think we're guided on a principle of
having an efficient and proportionate
governance system and not over
complicating things
um and so on that basis we would like
the Mandate and the support from the
board and to enhance I think the
connectivity of start well in the start
World board but to explore the future
role of the live well and age well
boards and also any other thematic
groups that would have once reported
into the health and well-being board to
make sure we have the right membership
the really a real Clarity of purpose so
that we are not having meetings for
meetings sake we haven't got the luxury
or the capacity to do in this time and
age so it really is about making sure
we're operating in an efficient way and
honing our efforts in on our big circuit
priorities to make the biggest
difference
important to note that the health and
well-being world has to act as that
influencer and connector across the
system and that will be supported
um by Democratic services in the Health
and Social CARE program management
office to make sure that coordination of
agendas and sequencing
um is is really strong we've suggested
that given that we've um in principle
agree to six meetings per year the last
time that we met in January that we we
follow through with that
um and that we have those meetings based
on the fact that we have a very
extensive work program where possible we
will sequence that with other governance
um but also it fits very well with the
five deep Dives and an annual refresh as
well so um some method behind the
madness there in terms of having uh
bi-monthly meetings
to really enhance and enable us to
deliver on our priorities I think it's
extremely important we review the
membership and within the paper it
outlines I think strengthening and
reconfirming the individuals the key
individuals from Partners
um around the table today as to those
memberships moving forward but also to
strengthen our current membership and
and we've we've put and we've listed
four different um sectors organizations
departments within the paper around the
place director within the council
um a traffic GP board Leisure and social
housing as the sectors and the
representation that we really feel
actually we need round this table to
affect some of the wider determinants of
Health to ensure that actually the work
plan that we've developed is deliverable
without those Partners we think it
becomes extremely difficult so we would
welcome the board support through
outside of this meeting identify the
individuals who will add that value and
to the health and wellbeing board
sorry this is a long paper
um the chairing Arrangements we did have
a
um we did have a a a culture a set of
Arrangements prior to the establishment
of the ICB and we are suggesting
um that Jane um in in her executive
member of all for health and well-being
inequalities
um becomes the the soul chair of this
forum moving forwards noting that the
ccg and that chair role does not exist
anymore but actually more fundamentally
it's because of the excellent
connections and and the role of of of
chair on the ICP board which goes back
to the previous conversation we've just
had and I think I will pause at that
point and apologies it took quite a long
time there's lots of individual elements
to that thank you thank you Tom it's
really interesting when you start to
have a look at what we need to do and
you know it's it's really important work
and we we need to get it right because
we don't have
you know we don't have that much time do
we so over to you Eleanor are you doing
are you doing a bit
heart specific Ally so what we try to do
is
apologies what we've been trying to do
is focus down as Tom said there's a very
broad remit that could be covered by the
board and that there are some statutory
things that have to come here but what
we've been trying to do is really focus
down on five key areas which will make
the biggest difference to our healthy
life expectancy and to reducing the
inequalities in those measures
we've tried having we've we've had these
as our priorities for a long time and
I'm I'm really pleased how well they fit
with the greater Manchester pieces of
work as well so when as Tom says when
when we looked at the greater Manchester
work and we're asked the question do we
need to review our strategy I very much
feel we don't need to review our
strategy it's very much in line and I
think the more that we can do that is
that aligns us to Greater Manchester and
gets the support from greater Manchester
but also sometimes maybe put some
pressure back into greater Manchester
about delivery the better what we've
tried to do and what's really different
I think about the approach we've we've
been taking now is that we have to
um looked at our 5K areas with those
deep Dives over the summer and we filled
we've now completed a template for each
area there's a collectivity smoking
mental health healthy weight and
alcohol
um and
put together the actions that we think
that if we work together as partners and
hold ourselves to account as partners
will make the big difference by putting
them into a program of work that we have
timetabled over a year that gives us the
opportunity to return to those pieces of
work once each per year and by having it
supported through a pmo approach we'll
be able to be doing some escalation
where where we have drifts so um I think
you'll when you look at the targets that
we have for each area the physical the
tobacco and the alcohol work basically
is based around to a starting point of
developing and improving our knowledge
on the area and the and our
understanding through the joint needs
joint strategic needs assessment of what
we need to be doing and developing a
senior partnership approach that then
reports in the case of alcohol back up
to here and to the safer traffic
partnership for the other for the
tobacco one coming back in here
but really gives those those groups an
opportunity to have a good look bearing
in mind what's happening nationally and
at Regional level about what the key
actions are for us are with some of the
physical activity and food
um and weight actions they're much more
specific about some particular programs
that we're thinking of investigating and
seeing if we can Implement so quite a
lot of this will be about exploration
and I'm testing the art of the possible
but what we're really asking people to
do as representatives of your
organizations on this board is to sign
up to engage in with us on this approach
and each taking the responsibility for
ensuring that you and your organization
are represented in the groups committed
to the work and problem solving with us
on some of the areas that may be tricky
and then bringing back and escalating
areas where we feel you know either
there's a there's a genuine barrier how
we overcome that what what do we do but
really trying to strive for excellence
on all of these not being put off by it
being difficult because some of this if
it wasn't here if we weren't bringing if
it was easy we wouldn't be needing to do
this through this forum with these
people so these are the things that are
going to be difficult but they will make
a difference so it's asking us to be
strong and brave and work together on
these and um really explore the Arts of
the possible so I'm really we're really
asking I suppose the two questions the
two asks we have at the board is to
agree the recommendations as Tom has set
them out agree the approach we're taking
and to support us with this next stage
of work which has worked for all of us
and in that engagement in that
thank you Elena does anybody have any
questions or comments
anything
just just
um just really welcome the the
objectives which really focus on genuine
prevention I mean given the the
challenges in the fiscal climate which
goes outlined earlier
um it's often an area that can be quite
easily overlooked and has massive
advantages longer term in terms of
keeping people well but also out of
statutory services so really welcome the
approach thank you so
um can we agree the recommendations on
the paper oh yeah sorry again
I support the recommendations it was
just a comment on the smart paper you
know that you have supplied with this
and it's just each of the groups it
seems to have very similar membership so
perhaps we need to think about maybe
expanding that a little bit across other
partners because I know that's probably
the intention
in fact I know is intention it just
seems to be four people on all of the
groups and I don't think that's possible
to do that on their own is it so I think
we all get involved I think if at the
when we bring each of these back for
each of the Deep dive reviews if we've
still got the fourth for only the same
four key people we've failed so I think
it's what we've put there is the people
who are charged with getting it started
but they are not the people who are
going to be able to deliver on their own
because if they could they would be
doing it now
um and they're you know so these are the
the key people that we've identified but
what we'll be looking at is your support
for when those four key people start
approaching you or your organization for
you to give your support to releasing
people's time and and engaging with this
and I think that will be one of the key
things that we'll be looking back when
we come back to each topic or where
we'll be bringing a escalation
um back in is if if we can't get the
reach into the organizations that's
where we'll be coming back to this board
and saying please help us with this
thank you Elena and Heather uh thanks I
think one of the um key things about
this is about communication and it's
about Behavior change and what we've got
to be able to do is to be able to get
the messages about
you know as to what we need to do and
and I know that we do do a lot on health
messaging and so on but you know we need
to be absolutely Relentless about it
because if we're not people have
everyday concerns and worries about
their own lives and they're not going to
think about the longer term
implications because you know now I want
to worry about the price of conflates
today rather than you know the fact that
you know I might live 10 years less so I
do think that there is a big
communication
um challenge here thanks thank you for
sharing that's really good point and
Jamie and then Eleanor thank you
just on that Heather absolutely agree
with you and it's not just communication
it's engagement but I think we've also
got a really good opportunity now in
Trafford with the development of the
neighborhood plans our integrated ways
of working are much better relationships
with our vcsf v c s FSE sector and and
we really would want our neighborhoods
to be looking at the this work and
thinking about how do they engage with
that because as you say for most people
you know you just don't think about your
health day to day you're just trying to
keep the show on the road aren't you so
what we need to be doing as
professionals and um and others working
in this field is to make sure that
people's daily lives are as good as
possible as easy as and that those
healthy choices become as easy as
possible for people to make so um but
absolutely that engagement side is
critical and I'm really enthusiastic
because of the work we've done with the
with the in the neighborhoods and with
the community hubs that we've got some
really good vehicles for that now in
Trafford
Nathan's comment before really in terms
of it's really good to see this as a
preventative agenda being at a Forefront
you know got a lot of work going across
sport Leisure physical activity movement
how all of that sizing is really
important so it's good to see that
coming through as a golden thread and
even picking up on Heathers coming
around Behavior change as well how how
Sports is that into Leisure can play a
role on a place-based approach
community-based approach with that as
well
thank you I think there were some really
good comments back there so thank you
Tom and we'll approved this now oh no no
Karen Karen got another one sorry just
to kind of wrap it up um obviously as
Director of Education and you know
schools and children are on my
day-to-day stuff I think um sort of
Eleanor and Tom thinking about this if
it is all around prevention you know
we've got some schools there are massive
assets they're connecting in with
farmers and children and young people
all of the time and so I think you know
don't forget them as a really powerful
partner but also thinking about the
rollout the family hubs as well and very
much around the family help agenda so I
think there's some great opportunities
there as well to help push this work
through
absolutely Karen could I mean the
schools and the way that the schools
work and the knowledge that schools have
their children their families is just
second to none and we saw us in the
pandemic and we continue to see it so
the schools have got to be a huge
delivery vehicle for a lot of this
so I think we've agreed that so thank
you madelina and if we can move on to
item eight and partner Partington
leveling up and that's you Jamie yes
thank you very much thank you thank you
chair for those who don't know me I'm
head of leisure Trafford Council room
across Leisure sport physical activity
and sports events I think this agenda
item is broadly an extension of last
month's agenda item where we talked
about traffic moving and the sport of
physical activity strategy and that's a
place place place
based approach a targeted intervention
focused on that reduction of Health
inequalities
and in many ways Traffic moving is it
forms everything we do it's our North
Star you know informs our measure
investment program reforms our playing
pitch strategy and it's really informed
this love funding application which has
been successful so hopefully that brings
us to today's items as a bit of a
context setting
um so to support today's agenda item I
assume people have outside of the exact
report the site map and the governance
structure so I'll focused probably on
the site map and the governance
structure and try and bring a bit of
Life a narrative to them and in terms of
the site map
it looked kind of warped on on the thing
that was shared so I've gone to the
trouble of printing tomorrow even on
color and so drama to handsome
I found a color printer in the council
so um
foreign
context Partington as we all know
suffers from generational disengagement
with sport physical activity so we
didn't want to just look at this from a
purely Leisure opportunity we wanted to
create an activity Commodore that
connects sport that connects Leisure
that connects physical activity with the
green space and that local community not
everyone we acknowledge that not
everyone engages with leisure so it's
around how the people are engaged with
team sports how do people want to engage
with the voluntary sector how do people
engage with outdoor space how does Sport
physical activity support social
outcomes and how can we just get more
people active and it was this activity
Corridor rather than just a focus on the
Leisure Center on that side that was
really the strength of the bid
um so I'll just sort of work through
some of the items that we've got start
with the Leisure Center it's a full
refurbishment of a retired 1970s
um Leisure Center we're really looking
at how we can make this space really
welcoming really inviting you know a
sense of arrival a sense of pride in the
place and how we can really create a
flexible facility mix within that space
we need to think about the size of
Parkington so what is the need what is
the demand thinking about how we make
the most of each space so if we have a
studio which we want to have for
exercise
there's not enough people in the area
for just
a studio so it's how can that become a
conference room how can that become an
event space how can we swept sweat every
space to get the most value out of it
equally thinking about meeting rooms how
can we bring in different services to
create a health and well-being Hub
rather than just a Leisure Center so if
you've got meeting rooms how can
neighborhood teams use it from voluntary
sector use it how can it support local
events and parties how can it create
training spaces to support the skills
agenda that's wrapped around the whole
of the leveling up bid equally
leisure in some ways if you don't get it
right can be quite cold you call me you
pay your membership you use the gym you
go home and and when we look at the
benefits of move ermstone actually it's
becoming a community Hub it's about
having a cafe it's about having a place
to have a conversation it's about people
feeling welcome it's about the start of
a journey it's about the end of a
journey it's about how it connects the
whole site together so it's about how
that Leisure Center becomes the Hub and
we've had a look around a different size
Beauty and Dunham in Warrington was a
great example of this so we're trying to
take some of the learning that they've
got as well as some of the other love
love projects in how we create that
space and so that's the Leisure Center
there's a number of different sort of
elements to this sort of project the one
is the pump track so improving a BMX
pump track but equally trying to make
sure that that's connected to a youth
offer so we're doing a lot of work
alongside the um the youth center which
is run by greater Manchester United
Federation so how can you have a BMX
site there how could not be linked to
programs how can the you fed house the
bikes how can they deliver programs how
can we create a little activity Corridor
for children and young people and
equally we're looking at refurbishing
full refurbishment across Lane changing
rooms
we're trying to build on the legacy of
the women's Euros about brilliant women
jurors that was do you know opening game
was a um oh Trafford and we've got a
legacy program that's been delivered and
delivered well how can women how can
girls feel safe happen to feel secure
getting changed in a space so
refurbishing that equally
local clubs such as a boxing club engage
really well so how can they have a space
within that building
um
Partington as a lot of you will know is
full of cul-de-sacs it's full of dark
spaces it's full of Alleyways that you
know people don't necessarily feel safe
so we've built in a public and we've
done some work around the public realm
and the trim Trail so it's a walk in a
running space which you'll be able to
see from that yellow line running around
the park so it's about providing people
with a space that they feel safe to run
feel safe to walk how can we bring other
activities such a park run into that
space which has worked really well in
other sites such as Longford Park
um and then access this this whole site
is is so constrained in terms of access
so for example if you live on the other
side of Warburton Lane which is on the
north side of this sort of site map
which is the largest part of the Pint
and estate you've got in some ways dog
like it all the way around Chapel Lane
to get into the Leisure Center so this
orange line here that sort of says new
connecting walk would be sort of
a strum that runs all the way through
the site so that we're connecting the
site with the local community so that
someone from that side of the estate can
walk to the Leisure Center you can walk
to the football pictures then get over
to the BMX track equally making sure
that lines of sight can connect the two
spaces so that people can see sport
physical activity taking space in the
Leisure Center people can look out of
the Leisure Center and see sport
physical activity movement taking place
within those green spaces as well to try
and connect the two through lines of
sight as well equally wayfinding so did
a lot of consultation with a lot of
parents and residents and there's not a
lot of signage up around Partington and
one of the things that really struck me
was engage the family
um in the in the Town Center of
Parkington asked them about the park
they didn't know there was a parking
Partington so and they lived there 20
years still didn't know there's a
parking pattern so um we really need to
build on that way finding so that
everyone understands what's in of our
Partington and then this is broadly a
capital build Capital fund but wrapped
around this whole piece as a skills
agenda so thinking about how
people from local painting can be
engaged from you know um
inactivity through a skills agenda into
autonomy into that community Through
skills through education through
training through employment thinking
about how we support that through the
different partners and stakeholders that
are brought into this project as well
and then lastly just on the site map is
about how
that complements what's already going on
in patented we know that you know
there's a lot of services in part in we
know that as a health and well-being
hope in the Town Center so it's about
not duplicating things it's about
complimenting them we're trying to put a
structure
um around that a governance structure
that hopefully helps see that
conversation too
and I'll come on to the governor
structure in a minute but I just I'd
also mention that
we can't just build it and expect people
to come there's examples of where that
hasn't worked so we need to
be clear and understand those examples
so that we don't fall to that same issue
it's about those Behavior changes to
support engagement so we're trying to
find that sweet spot between the capital
funding and the revenue so having good
conversations with sport England the
greater Sport and a local delivery pilot
Legacy funding that will help support
this agenda equally
um
we're looking at the prosperity funding
as well so that Leisure we can work with
traffic Leisure about supporting them to
engage in that local community and
bringing Leisure out of the center into
the local community building up Social
Capital so that when the building's open
we can bring that Community back in and
we've got a good sort of balance of
those working in and out of that space
and that's the site map broadly I'll go
to governance in a minute but is there
any questions on the site map
I haven't got a question but I just
think that you know the plant looks
absolutely brilliant and I think that
the thought that's gone into that to
make it accessible and for people and
you know the stuff that you're going to
be doing around and safety for women and
girls I think is really important and
what we need to do is we need to get
that communication out into the
community so that they understand where
it is because if you don't tell people
they won't come so you know we need to
be making sure that the communication is
really clear and easy to understand and
and you know signpost people to it
because it you know it's it's going to
be a brilliant
um
it's going to be brilliant for Parkinson
to have this there and you know because
they are so deprived in that area
because they're so cut off and and this
is going to sort of make a big change
for it for for our residents health and
well-being there so thanks for that but
I think Karina wants to say something
um yeah thank you um um I am incredibly
excited and I was the councilor in
Partington
um when we got the fuse building so I
was interested to hear what you said
around the capital versus Revenue
spending because we got a big shiny new
building which was shot within 18 months
because the government had provided the
capital but nothing to help us run it
and obviously you know sort of redeeming
our communities now run that and so I
was pleased to hear what you were saying
about working with other organizations
because obviously they like to run
meetings and weddings and stuff from
their venue as well so we wouldn't want
to be competing with that but
um
I think it's interesting that you're
you're mindful that we can have shiny
buildings but we also need people to
look after and engage yeah
the core principle if the bid's live on
our website I can direct people to it
it's all around that behavior change
it's all around
um that generational disengagement with
sport physical activity if you look at
our Borough broadly speaking we're quite
healthy quite wealthy but actually
parenting is that red spot in in that
issue so it allows your traffic moving
but equally
we know that we need to focus on this
space and we know what we can't just
build something there are a lot of
services within Partington but we're not
getting the outcomes that we want so
it's about how
not just those the voluntary the
voluntary sector and you know how
everyone plays into it so we're trying
to create
a governance structure that allows that
conversation to happen early and to move
on to the governance structure
sorry yeah yeah I mean I think it's um
fantastic
um that you know pattington's been able
to attract the money I've just got three
points really the first is about
yesterday's uh announcements in the
budget
um as it impacts on greater Manchester
that's going to provide us with uh
greater freedoms and opportunities about
how money is spent locally and if
there's any uh way in which you would be
able to access that when more detail
becomes known so that was one point the
other one I think I've raised previously
and that's about uh concessions because
that is related very much to the cost of
living and when people are struggling to
heat and eat and go into the local
Leisure Center isn't necessarily
um high on their agenda so I think that
that's important
um and the other one that I hadn't
thought about previously was about
police involvement and the safety of
women and the point you've just made
about there being lots of cul-de-sacs
and things in Partington and are we
involving the police in any of these
discussions so that we can highlight
some of these issues with them thanks
over to you Jamie to respond and then
move us on I think I think the budget
announcement is really good point we
need to keep sight of that
um in terms of concessions you're right
it's a challenge within the Leisure
sector
um trying to provide a price point that
supports
those most in need of this um to access
it so we're doing a review of our
concessions price
um which will feed into pie into power
so our broader Leisure offer so did I
think it's a really valid point and
equally pleased
um we've had over 40 stakeholders
engaged in this in this bid to a point
um I think police is maybe a gap and we
should try and bring them in to the
conversation
thanks chair just to pick up your point
initially um Heather about the
Trailblazer announcement which I think
is what you're referring to isn't it
from the government one of the
um commitments that was announced
yesterday as part of that Trailblazer
with greater Manchester was that um
there would be a single settlement for
GM which essentially means that um a
range of resources which often come down
in silos government silos or indeed
where
um go to Manchester and authorities have
to bid for it will be allocated to go to
Manchester in order that greater
Manchester can invest it
um to support the greater Manchester and
the constituent parts of Greater
Manchester priorities
um the focus of that funding is around
housing regeneration economic growth
transport digital those kinds of areas
but over the course of the coming months
the detail as to exactly how it's going
to work work and what we can spend that
resource on and how we can spend that
resource will become clearer so there
are lots I think of opportunities there
for us to support and enable what we're
talking about today in terms of the um
the leveling up from proposal not least
one of the challenges is accessibility
isn't it
um in uh into and out of and around
Partington and the opportunities to use
that Transport Funding I think a really
really important could I just make a
just a second Point as well just in the
context of the um
the governance
um charts that you have included Jamie
I'm conscious that we talk about
Community as Community groups and sports
groups and great that we're involved in
those in helping develop the um the
plans but I suppose what I would um and
I'm sure you will have an answer to this
I would worry a little bit if we're just
focusing on those because generally
they'll be the motivated people who are
already involved in stuff in their
communities and activity-wise so just
the thought around how we engage much
more broadly in
um in Partington so that we um we can
Infuse and and also understand actually
why
um we've got a Leisure Center there
which has been
um quite significantly underused hasn't
it so so that would be the other point
well thank you hugely exciting I think
the point that Karen made earlier around
engaging with schools I think that's
really important because if we encourage
youngsters to go they'll encourage the
parents to come along so I think that
you know that's a really good resource
that we can tap into so if you want to
move on thank you
um so I think in terms of the other
piece I wanted to just labor today was
the governance structure which
try to show how we sort of work from CLT
through to Leisure board all the way
through to the capital project and that
key Point around stakeholder engagement
I think the strength of the bid is that
we had 40 plus stakeholders you know
input on this bid input on this concept
and this idea
um the challenges we've got foreign plus
stakeholders that you know we need to
work with on a tight timeline and
deliverables so we're trying to put a
covenant structure that gives everyone a
voice and that early engagement
um slide seven is probably the most
poignant to talk about that in terms of
stakeholder engagement where you've got
how we try to group it is in three
groups based on the outcomes of the bid
um the stakeholders we've got today
um they are one it is a health group led
by Jane Hines with support from John
Brady from my team around engaging all
of those Health Providers thinking about
how they want to engage with their space
thinking about how they want to engage
with the Leisure Center thinking about
do they want to be housed at the Leisure
Center is there any sort of primary care
second care you know what sort of
services do we want within that space is
it clinical is it non-clinical because
if
we are to build it around those spaces
we need to know now so that we can start
that process now so that grid will help
focus on that equal that will help focus
on how else does Health while being
involved in that space is it
uh the green spaces is it is it social
prescribing is it physical activity
referrals what does that look like so we
use that Forum to progress that
then
um we've got the second week which is
around Community sports clubs Community
voluntary sector
um how do they what I'll be involved in
in the space you know there's a lot of
stakeholders that are put into the bid
there's a lot of people that are doing
work within the space how can we develop
them how can they engage in the space
how can we look at their
um program reviews and make sure that
that then pivots into the skills agenda
which is around actually we've got UA 92
that they said they want to deliver a
degree course from this space which I
think is amazing you've got a proactive
School you've got primary schools you've
got traffic Leisure offering jobs you've
got um
you've got my new foundation so you've
got that whole engagement from you know
sort of disaffected Youth um lack of
Engagement through to autonomous in the
community and it's about how that skills
agenda supports all of that and so
they're the key sort of groups that
we've set out for the the stakeholder
engagement they then feed into a broader
sort of Steering group which sits over
both the stakeholder groups and the
capital groups as well so um
what we're going to do is we can
revocalize the loft bed in terms of
within this space we've taken it to the
Health and Social care steering groups
as well and so we feel like we've got a
good traction good engagement so now
it's a point of not just getting those
meeting out getting those dates set
getting those dates set for the Steering
group and the stakeholder groups so that
we can start to make some progress
um on that
thank you Jamie and I think that it was
good that you noticed that um we noted
around other people coming into the site
as well because I know that we do have
um a gap in our Urgent Care around
Pharmacy and and Partington so it may be
that we'll be able to pick something up
and within that site and going forward
so I think that's really important that
you've given others the opportunity to
come in and use the site as well any
comments on
the report no thank you very much Jamie
that was really excellent thank you
and then if we can move on to the
employment Charter and real living wage
accreditation I think it's really really
good that yeah that we're going to be um
moving to look to get well looking to
get accreditation for it and become a
living wage employer because we are
actually paying 10 pound 90 now to our
and directly employed staff and um are
directly
um maintained schools so I think it's
really positive it's you know it's part
of our agenda about living lifting
people a part of poverty so over to you
thank you very much
then
[Music]
I don't know
oh thank you
I'll just go for it so okay know what it
says
hi everyone um I'm Emma Mosley and I'm a
policy officer I've been working towards
traffic council's accreditation for the
real living wage
and so as of January 2023 320 directly
employed staff at the council and also
at schools were given an uplift to
rise them up to real living wage
so that means that um now everyone who's
directly employed by the council is
being paid for a living wage
this enabled us to apply for quotation
which we did recently we haven't heard
back yet but we're very hopeful
and apply of quotation involves agreeing
to a three-year procurement plan working
with eligible contracted suppliers to
support them to pay their own wage to
their employees this includes eligible
contracts totaling up to 10 million
pounds over the next three years
so this is all part of GM's commitment
to become a real living wage city
um and they've done a lot of research
into this
so luckily the number of jobs that are
being paid real living wage is currently
fallen in the last decade so we are
making progress in this area but there's
quite a lot of
um things to consider around equalities
especially part-time work tends to be a
lower paid job women account for the
majority of people being paid below
reliving wage it's 12.5 of jobs that are
currently being paid low living wage in
Greater Manchester
younger and older workers are also part
of that and it's people in particular
sectors as well such as hospitality and
Retail
so these are all things that need to be
considered
so when you look at Trafford it's
interesting that our residents tend to
be paid more than real living wage
compared to national average but our
workplaces are there's more jobs they're
being people over every living wage
so when we do hopefully get our
accreditation it makes sense that we
concentrate more on our workplaces than
our residents are trying to rise up
those wage levels
so this is also connected to the good
employment Charter in order to be a
member of the good employment Charter
you need to be real living wage
accredited
so at the moment we are a supporter of
the greater Manchester good employment
Charter but we can't we can't remember
until we get that accreditation
so the greater Manchester employment
Charter is a voluntary membership and
assessment scheme that aims to raise
employment standards across GM for all
organizations of any size sector or
geography
so yeah real living wage is part of that
there's also a lot of commitments around
secure work flexible work recruitment
Health well-being for employees people
management and engagement and voice
thank you
so yeah there's the two tiers support
which is when you support the aims of
the charter and then member where you
have um enacted that Charter in your
organization
so hopefully we can move towards that
once we're accredited and we also have
plans to as I said support organizations
across Trafford to become real living
wage credited and to hold an annual
event on good employment with partners
So yeah thank you very much
thank you and I think it's really good
that we're going to be looking to move
to be um part of the good employment
Charter I think that that's really
important because if people have got
secure work they can make decisions
about where they live what they purchase
all those kind of things and to pay 10
pound and 90 I think you know it's a
great start for us and you know
being a trade unionist I think we should
be paying a lot more but um I think that
you know we are where we are with the
financial situation so I think it's
excellent work and thanks for all your
hard work or any comments or questions
Heather hey yeah there's two things that
occur to me were about training and
about career Pathways and given that
there are a lot of women that are paid a
lot less than men in some instances uh
those two things would be really really
important
um it was just really I was interested
in the differences between our residents
and our workplaces and particularly the
thing that really struck me actually was
that Barry has the same proportion of
its residents who were below the real
living wage than we do but Barry is a
much less affluent Borough so I'm
presuming that's just because they have
fewer people up at the top end of the
pay scales but the other question was
really looking at that variation in
workplaces and really quite Stark
variation in workplaces that are and
aren't paying um the real living wage
I'm wondering how much work and I'm sure
there has been work done on what types
of workplaces these are and how we um
whether there are particular actions we
need to be taking at a greater
Manchester level to support the local
action with particular sectors of our
economy
um there's definitely a lot of research
out there that shows particular sectors
are as you say pay a lot less
um they could we could definitely do
more work around Trafford once we have
the accreditation that's something we
can look at what needs to be targeted
but we have a very good idea about which
sectors like hospitality
and Retail so yeah we definitely know
where to go next
foreign
yeah I think I really welcome the
accreditation and I wouldn't say this
given given my role but uh in Health and
Social care absolutely critical that
we're paying the real living wage and I
was at an event last night with the the
Army and they're struggling to recruit
so recruitment is a challenge across the
piece and if we need a a really well
functioning Health and Social care
Workforce that they have to be paid
proportionately in wholeheartedly agree
with the chair obviously this is just
the starting point
um but we have to get Health and Social
care onto that footing if we want a
sustainable model
exactly and you know I think that just
looking at people taking industrial
action over the last couple of months if
you have a look at you know
um our Junior doctors they get paid less
than and somebody working in prep not
saying that somebody in pratts doesn't
get the wages they do because I think
that everybody should get the rate for
the job book clearly our Junior doctors
are not getting the rate for the job so
no wonder people are leaving health and
we need to retain them so we need to be
making sure that good employment is
right across the piece thank you Kevin
yeah just kind of building on what
Nathan just shared I know um within the
child care sector we're really seeing
struggles now
um thinking about part internationally
um we're getting really concerned about
the number of providers that are having
to close
um just because of a real issue around
recruitment which is clearly going to
frustrate the ability for for families
and and particularly women as well to be
able to find employment uh you know and
thinking about what the government's
gender is around trying to provide that
paid for child care but we actually need
the child care for them to be able to
attend so it's just something as well I
think is worth considering and
potentially how we grow our own as well
within that
thank you any further questions or
comments no thank you and thanks for all
your hard work and look forward to when
we get our badge
thank you
and if we can move on now to uh item 10
. and it's you Gareth yeah thank you
I'll start I'm sure Nathan wants to
contribute as well so this is a verbal
update last meeting we brought the 22-23
uh better care fund I'm including the
new um annexes for the additional
discharge funding that we received and
that year so so that's been and gone and
we're heading into the new Financial
year so we're currently working on the
better care fund for 23.24
not expecting a huge number of changes
but there are some complications this
year I'm including the delegations from
the ICB down to the locality board which
have been agreed now and one of the
three parts of the locality board is a
section
section 75 joint committee between the
council and the ICB that's really
positive I think one of the
complications is that some of the
elements that I'm included in the better
care fund are part of wide NHS contracts
which aren't delegated down to locality
boards we're working through through
that governance but I think we'll get
there and we will have something to sign
off formally in April it's just a
question of the committee how we do that
because I know we're not going to have
another meeting
of the health and wellbeing board in the
next month or two and as we saw in the
terms of reference you know it's a form
a fundamental statutory role of the
health and wellbeing board so we will be
in a position
to have the better care Fund in April
it's just thinking about the governments
and maybe we need to delegate that final
authorization
to ourselves as officers and yourself as
chair but you know take comments on that
but not expecting any huge changes from
what we've got he's just working through
that governance complication which which
we weren't expecting let's say when we
were talking about at the locality board
so I'll pause them and anything to add
Nathan in terms of the process and just
the the criticality of obviously the
health and well-being board and decision
making
um given that is
um
the the driver Force signing off and
ultimately agreeing the content of the
section 75
um but I think it's important to know
about section 75 has a significant
number of adult care services in there
as well so as well as the the health
services and the the agreement does
obviously allow us to to work across and
between Health and Social care but it's
worth noting about there are things like
home care and critical services covered
in that as well
any comments so
um can we go with the recommendation
that because we're not going to be able
to meet again that we can take a
delegated decision and when um
Gareth and Nathan have a bit more
information
um you know actual scareth with the
money I know that he just wouldn't
I know
I do I do it's just an implicitly come
on Sarah
I'm just conscious I mean it is one of
the the statutory responsibilities of
this board is it not to sign off
um on those arrangements so perhaps if
what we commit to is circulating the
um the section 75 once we've got it
there and give people the opportunity to
come back ask any questions raise any
issues and then
um you know a week or sufficient time so
people can do that with the delegation
then to to you as chair I think in
consultation
um with officers
a little happy with that yeah thank you
Sarah that's sounds great so can we
agree that going forward yeah thank you
and if we do want to say some more about
section 75 agreement with mft
it's important to know that this is is
reading conjunction with the the better
careful because there is a significant
overlap between obviously the delivery
of Community Health Services
um I think one of the things that it's
important to to note in the report is
the history of the section 75 so it's
been in place in various guises since
2013 which is Testament to Trafford
being really committed to health
integration and being a real early
adopter of that
um in terms of this specific report it
was considered by the council executive
on on Monday the 13th
and so it's coming to board for noting
um but the the section 75 does enable
um the functions of the Trafford local
Care Organization which is delivered by
mft and the council to come together
um to deliver really critical services
so the discharge to assess service at
Ascot house for instance is covered
under this agreement and the One-Stop
resource center and under and elements
of the control room and the ability for
staff to work across boundaries be
managed by Health if they're employed by
the council and vice versa to utilize a
state
um is absolutely critical as part of our
integration Journey
um a full list of the services in scalp
is in the report of section 3.1
and so I won't go into them in detail
but the aim for this section 75 is to
use to
2023-24 to develop the the operating
model for the um the the TLC hours it's
known in Trafford local Care
Organization and so it's not really
clarify and strengthen the vision so
people are really clear what what the
community offer is
um but also
giving permissions to develop
um subject to the correct governance of
course
um abilities to to look at what further
collaboration and different offers
um and one of the one of the things
we're looking at at the moment is how we
can facilitate more people to go home
and overcome barriers such as housing
you know housings being quite a critical
issue in terms of people staying in
hospital for a very long time and so
that suitable offer or step down whilst
we find a super offer is one of the the
key uh components that we're looking at
collectively between
mft staff in the tlco and the council
and ricb colleagues so really good
example of collaborative working across
the beat
thank you any questions at all comments
just note the report thank you
we've had a letter from the
um ICB Regional director of well
actually the regional director of
performance and Delivery for the North
West asking us about our views health
and well-being board on where the
greater Manchester integrated care board
could go further in supporting the
delivery of our local health and
well-being board strategy so I think
given the conversation we've had today
we've actually had and and given that
we've discussed the locality plan
um the three questions I think we've got
quite a lot of things to answer on that
um uh the three questions they've had is
how effectively has the greater
Manchester ICB worked with the NHS and
wider system Partners in order to
implement our plan and I think
um we've got so many examples of things
that have been done at a greater
Manchester as well as locally so whether
you look at the great um greater
Manchester moving
um some of the the making smoking
history the work that Sally was just
describing earlier
we've so I think we've got lots of
examples but I also think looking at the
population Health Plan and the
conversations that we were having
earlier there are some things that we
might want to be reinforcing within that
particularly around the metrics the
measurement the time scales of the
delivery of some of that that we might
want to feed back
um I know people in the room haven't had
very long to look at this letter we've
started to put together a response my
suggestion is if people have comments
now that would be fantastic and we will
feed them in but we have till the
seventh of
um April to reply to this so my my
suggestion is that we will draft up a
response we will send it we'll
we're asking you now to send any of your
thoughts through we will draft up a
response which we will circulate I think
the um
I can't even think what day of the week
the 7th of April is to be honest but the
Friday before whatever that is unless
it's definitely not a Monday so that we
can if you could get us your comments
back on the letter that we will draft
plus feed us any other comments in uh we
will then submit that um if if it's okay
with the board we will ask for Chaz
action to submit that letter
I do like working on a good Friday
um so I think we'll be saying then the
previous Friday and we will be getting
that letter in I suggest on the 6th if
that's okay with Council Slater
yeah that's that's fine and so
people can feed back towards or if
you've got comments now that's really
really helpful because it can sort of
set the scene for us and if not if we
can have those comments in terms of
feeding back if you email them directly
to me that's probably the easiest way to
do it
um and I'll I'll take responsibility for
drafting the reply so
can the board Note the contents give us
some feedback and Eleanor will make sure
that that letter is ready for the sixth
I think I think the big Advantage will
be if there are things we specifically
think would be helpful this is a really
good opportunity because this will be a
different way of getting some of the
same messages we were talking about
around the locality work
um the the sorry the greater Manchester
plan in into that space via a different
route so
no it's short notice and it's just only
perhaps you've only just seen it for the
first time so if we can get the
information back by the 31st of March
for you and then we can get the letter
sent by the sixth
thank you so much everybody for that and
and there's nothing further so thank you
all and we've steamed through that
meeting so you can all have a bit of
your life's back and
um
we'll see you all in the new Municipal
year it may not be me
see you all then thank you
thank you